is my name welcome back to some more
happy wheels we can start up right away
hello again solid layer your mission
should you choose to accept it it's
infinite Pelican Bay
oh we're gonna kill those Pogo [ __ ]
so I'm sure this won't cause any fan
trouble Oh God what hey cuz I'm free oh
stop oh girls people they see me rollin
they Pogan Patrol and there's a bitter
drug dense toga ah [ __ ] me what are you
doing it in my [ __ ]
actually please proceed alright they see
me Pogue and they each announcer oh [ __ ]
bashed by waiting a big whoa what the
hell happened there yeah
leftovers room sorry every time I find a
badass move I gotta do yeah yeah no arms
yeah this is a regular day in happy
wheels 9 how you then that sure let me
just approach here with a hug I'm just
gonna try to bring my arms together
let's try to actually finish this I'm
sorry whoa I jumped I'm in mintage on
Polly's whoa it's raining blood
hallelujah oh god Wow that's how we roll
Pogo styled [ __ ] why would you kill
me like that silly Pogo people goddammit
let's try it again
I'm sorry if I suck at this they see me
ah that's leg that's okay I'll see you
later like oh no I was so badass why do
you have to count that goddamn all right
let's do the bad way
a little opposing wagon way I don't know
why I said like jump jump again
yep again you see that [ __ ] ah get him
man all right approach him nice and
easily right in my navel I call in
English there we go get eat your own
birthday run away oh you better run got
a sword in my dick sorry about your head
alright that's yes I was ah god damn it
I'll see you in a second come on Pogo
troppo no I'm not even commenting on
this [ __ ] alright here we go
oh no that's yes Oh plus quieter ah it's
okay just a min dick
yeah like it oh yeah oh yeah keep doing
that yeah yeah you're like that Pogo man
yeah oh yeah you can invest but eh oh
that's right that's right I tricked ya I
have an iron dick - no oh hey you're
coming with me
okay he's not coming that's okay well
you're coming
what no no I wants to come with me I
don't know why Best Buy hey what are you
doing I don't show me that helmet power
alright leftovers room all right though
right hand
come quickly destroyed em states of ice
they have this guy's doesn't oily
drinking it can't happen
don't let him near the stab your own
back that's right can you stop him
come that's how I roll
now I jump on your penis at some time oh
no - [ __ ]
there we go no my penis you're a woman
now you can thank me later
stop you can't be I know but I don't
care
Oh toilet stop hey you don't know
charlie come not every day you meet a
toilet with a certain in your dick
congratulations earlier ah thank you
yeah best finish ever hey all right
well I had fun at least let's try
another one
ninety-nine percent nine ninety nine
percent a challenge accepted sorry I
have to do it with it okay okay I
thought it was just a man bring it hard
tone oh hey look at this guy quite
comfortable thank you mine there we go
bring it hard pose come on harpoon show
me what you got
ah landmine is the problem what come on
let's try it harpoon bring it ah hey
Pogo you made it no way my feet made it
too actually I am still alive but just
yeah yeah yeah now I can swim in the
ocean and spray red pear
okay so that's how you get rid of that
[ __ ] now let's just get rid of you no
that's good yeah like it whoa what was
that
can I get loose maybe come on he was
really flexible he's like a yoga mat
he's good night you shouldn't be called
tokenized
should be called yep yoga man yeah but a
bunch am so clever ah yeah yeah that's
how I roll with hard phones in me come
Moby Dick doesn't know [ __ ] alright here
we go
ah [ __ ] step it hard tough that's my
hand doing there coming out of my butt
am I giving birth to a had I wanted to
give it birth to
I know whatever I can't do it sorry I
don't even know why I picked I suck at
these glass breakage I'm sorry
escape from what come to me son
okay that what hey I play this one
oh if you want her naked and no okay
not yet okay very interesting I wish I
would get gifts like that hey it's
another Sud well there's an that come
hey got you by a dick [ __ ] no don't let
me go uh tell me tell me should I let
you go oh that's right
really who's next
his neck huh that's right the person
next who's next I was thinking I love
shoving him in his dick and be like oh
yeah that's right that's how I double
throw oh okay let's go for God Oh
don't burn in your Paula ah [ __ ] I just
I don't know how you got it but whatever
ooh what is this
I'm Nisha oh I don't trust you shut up
so annoying
whoa damn this is not the time to sing
ah I need Aladdin I think god damn okay
I'm carrying the lantern but uh mr. Chan
what are you doing with that [ __ ]
I don't know hate that little [ __ ] side
of mine but like whoa this is pretty uh
well made holy [ __ ] share my pity all
right fine I don't care about the bro oh
[ __ ] man ah why would you do that
well that's what you get you little
pervert let's now let's make out I'm
finally unload your sick dad yes shut
offs and your dummy let's do some weird
[ __ ] in here oh the bedroom
ah that was them really hey it stole my
bike duh [ __ ] it looks like a penis
coming out all right whatever
oh you won't tell anyone about my
gayness what
your fudge
don't cheat on me what what are you
dying I'm gonna drive let's go I just
hang out
I'm scared what way can't even see any
show me this action I'm so happy
you're sick everybody okay I'm sorry
just calm down a little bed and I think
there was some texture to guide me go
back into the door warning he kills you
well no he made out with me some
bromance bromance go back until you hit
the wall watching yummy ah you already
pushing yeah just because I'm gay
doesn't mean um what did you what you're
truly gay
no I'm not god damn it you're gay shut
up okay
no you're yay yes yeah shut up just
kinda not getting anywhere with this gay
[ __ ] thanks you know offensive to a lot
of people who's watching just try to get
out this [ __ ] hell it's so fat
okay come on candy that's [ __ ]
difficult there we go holy [ __ ] daddy
you're such a [ __ ]
what the heck what are you talking about
you may my son yeah okay now just
blaming everything in barrels right now
that's right that's right pictures we
work with the Bass Pro one arm down
that's not Church whoa
the hell it yeah Big E again your
[ __ ] bare eyes and a front slip on my
way over here
whoa whoa Javad I was terrified my son
is so much Hey I was yep this knife
whoever made it
your birth is the Ottoman Safavid
syncline let's do some [ __ ] goons I
know this joke is kinda over used right
now by me all right this is more shall
we knife killing don't move sorry let's
do a knife killing Timmy all right you
like us Jets now I got you all tied down
that my wife I like [ __ ] I know she was
fat I lost my heart that doesn't matter
you will all die anyway come on you
later Oh double double ones first of the
double nesco choppa spice oh it's
snowing now cool stock nice pizza chef
I'm stuck with it double again double
care guys go for it suicide aah oh let's
try the suicide and grab that [ __ ] on
real room wow that was that [ __ ]
butcha oh stop killing yourself more to
me hey come on stop I don't want to kill
you all of it you're not the real Tim
stop dying a little fuzzy
stop tagging everything there we go
ok grab it now come on
see [ __ ] aah oh I got some neat [ __ ]
look at this
there we go more knives bring it doesn't
pop ok ahh dad let's one more try one
more try
it's no income I want to kill the real
one ok let's kill my mom not my mom my
wife
all right whatever it's pretty much it
like really enjoyed such kind of
coverage and I'll see you next episode
we're going to LA for Wednesday to
Sunday so if I don't post any videos you
know why following me on Facebook or
Twitter I actually never said that but
if you want to know what I do and staff
the naive will probably post something
really uninteresting there
are you doing down there
what yeah
it's gone here